[موسيقى]
لربما شكل العبور فوق الممرات المائيه
هاجسا لدى البشر منذ الازل فبداوا في
البحث عن طرق لربط اليابسه حتى خلصوا الى
صناعه الجسور التي بدات بطريقه بدائيه ثم
باتت فرعا مهما في كتب هندسه البناء فكيف
حدث ذلك
اذا ما سقطت جذوع الاشجار او الحجاره فوق
مجرى مائي تشكل جسرا طبيعيا فوق النهر فلم
يكن هناك خيارات للتنقل فوق الماء فبدا
الناس ببناء جسور بدائيه مستخدمين الجذوع
والواح الخشب والحجاره كما استخدموا
احيانا الياف طبيعيه منسوجه معا لتثبيتها
الكثير من الشواهد التي تركتها الحضارات
القديمه تشير الى وجود الجسور بالحضارات
القديمه كاشور ومصر ففي مصر مثلا عثر على
اقواس حجريه فوق مدخل الهرم الاكبر تعود
فتره بنائيه الى ما بين 3000
قبل الميلاد
اما اول جسر معترف به فيعود لنحو 4000 سنه
قبل الميلاد وينسب لبابل حيث وجد قوس كبير
امتد على طول نهر الفرات وصنع من الطوب
كذلك تغني الهنود بالجسور التي بنوها
باستخدام الخيزران والحديد في ادابهم
الملحمي الذي كتب بين القرنين الرابع
والثالث قبل الميلاد
اهم مراحل التقدم في العصر القديم ببناء
الجسور نسبت للرومان حيث بنوا العديد من
الجسور باستخدام اسمنت البوزولانا المكون
من الماء والجير والرمل والصخور البركانيه
استخدم الرومان القوس نصف الدائري
بتصميماتهم التي لا يزال العديد منها
قائما حتى اليوم كجسر القنطره الذي بني
فوق نهر تاغوس في اسبانيا كذلك وجد اقدم
جسر حجري مقوس بالعالم في الصين وهو جسر
في الفتره ما بين 500
وخمسه خلال عهد اسره سوي في فتره العصور
المظلمه توقف بناء الجسور حتى اعاده
الروبان في اوروبا بعصر النهضه حيث انشاوا
منازل عندما عابر الانهار لحمايه
المسافرين من قطاع الطرق وجعلوا حمايتها
واجبا مقدسا
في بدايه القرن الثامن عشر انشات فرنسا
اول دائره للجسور والطرق فيما تم بناء جسر
ويستمانستر الحديدي في انجلترا كما اعيد
استخدام مبدا التروس الذي يعود اكتشافه
للمهندس المعماري الايطاليو
خلال تلك الفتره انجزت العديد من الاعمال
بهندسه الجسور مثل كتاب سكوير ويبل
خلال القرن التاسع عشر سجلت البريطانيه
سارا غوبي براءه اختراعا لطريقه عمل
دعامات امنه للجسور كما انتشرت اشكال
مختلفه من الجسور كجسور السكك الحديديه
وجسور الكابلات التي لم تنجح فلم يعد
بناؤها كما شهدت ولايه بنسلفانيا بناء اول
جسر معلق حديث بامتداد 21 مترا
في عام
1927 تم بناء اول جسر ملحوم من قبل
المهندس البولندي سيفان برايلا واقامه فوق
نهر سودويا خلال القرن العشرين تطور تصميم
هياكل الجسور وباتت اخف وزنا ومن ابرزها
جسر سيفرن المعلق وجسر
اليوم لم تعد الجسور تستخدم للتنقل فوق
الممرات المائيه فبني الكثير منها فوق
المرافق والمنشات بالمدن الحديثه والريف
وباشكال واطوال متباينه حتى باتت الجسور
وعلامه تعكس مستوى التقدم المعماري للدول
ورفعتها